Long before the likes of Warren Buffet, Hetty
Green dominated Wall Street through extremely
shrewd investing, frugality, and exploiting
the lax investment rules of her age, managing
to amass one of the greatest fortunes in history.
Hetty, born Henrietta Howland Robinson in
1834, was the daughter of Edward and Abby
Robinson.
The family first made their fortune thanks
to Hetty’s great-grandfather who went to
sea as a whaler.
Within two generations, the family under the
guidance of Hetty’s father and maternal
grandfather amassed one of the biggest whaling
fleets in North America, with her father increasing
the family fortune twenty fold in his lifetime.
Hetty’s business education started early
at the tender age of six years old, reading
the financial news to her maternal grandfather,
Gideon Howland, whose failing eyesight prevented
him from doing it himself.
During these readings, her grandfather also
discussed what she was reading with her.
Two years later, Hetty opened her first bank
account.
Shortly thereafter, she began investing her
allowance.
By 13 years old, she took over management
of the family bookkeeping, which was no small
thing considering the many business deals
her father was involved in.
Needless to say, between helping her grandfather
and father in their respective business dealings,
Hetty was receiving a first class education
in the world of business.
As she exited her teen years, her father was
more interested in seeing Hetty married off
than becoming a successful businesswoman,
so purchased a $1200 wardrobe ($30,600 today)
for her to wear around Boston and New York
to attract wealthy men.
Hetty was “a good looking woman… [with]
angelic blue eyes” so this wouldn’t have
been a problem, but she had no interest in
it.
Upon receiving the gift of the wardrobe, Hetty
promptly sold off the clothing and invested
the money from the sale.
While she did well for herself with these
small sums, her “seed money” really jumped
after the death of her father when Hetty was
30 years old.
Hetty had previously been supposed to inherit
much of her mother’s estate upon her passing,
but her father took most of it for himself.
Rather than risk losing out on being the heir
to his more significant fortune, Hetty took
it in stride and did not bring a lawsuit against
her father.
She didn’t have to wait long for the money.
Her father died just five years after her
mother, bequeathing his entire estate to her,
which at this point had risen to about $5-$7
million ($75-$105 million today).
She promptly took the money she had instant
access too (much of it was left in a trust
for her to draw from annually) and invested
it in the highly risky (or so others thought)
U.S. Civil War bonds.
But even investing the money from her father
wasn’t enough for Hetty.
Her aunt, Sylvia Ann Howland, died within
a year of her father, but rather than leave
Hetty her fortune of about $2 million as she
had once said she’d do, she left most of
it to charity, her doctor and caretakers,
and some of Hetty’s cousins.
This didn’t sit well with Hetty, who had
taken to heart something her father had once
told her, “…never give anyone anything,
not even a kindness.”
Thus, Hetty challenged the will, even going
so far as forging a new one that stated her
aunt’s fortune should be left to Hetty.
In the end, Hetty lost the case of “Robinson
v. Mandell” with the court determining the
signature on the will was a forgery.
However, in the end, Hetty was able to wrangle
approximately $600,000 out of her aunt’s
estate.
In the interim, Hetty married a successful
businessman, Edward Green, in 1867, but not
before getting him to agree to keep all finances
separate and that neither of them was entitled
to any of the others’ money.
The fact that Hetty had tried to swindle away
her aunt’s estate via forging a will didn’t
sit well with a few of Hetty’s cousins.
To avoid the legal troubles that were headed
her way, Hetty and her husband moved to England.
While there, besides increasing her already
vast fortune by continuing to heavily invest
in the United States (this time investing
in greenbacks and railroads in the U.S., and
later in U.S. real estate mortgages, among
other things), Hetty also had two children,
Edward “Ned” Green (1868) and Harriet
Sylvia Green (1871).
Once the statute of limitations was up on
her former legal problems, the Greens moved
back to the United States in 1875.
In 1885, it was discovered that her decision
to keep her finances separate from her husband’s
was a wise one.
Hetty staunchly practiced principles such
as always keeping large sums of cash in reserve;
investing heavily when others were being conservative;
cashing out when everyone else was bullish
(rarely hanging on to investments long term,
selling as soon as something hit the price
she had originally been looking for when she
bought it); never accumulating any debt; keeping
a cool head in any crisis; and incessantly
researching any investment before making it.
Her husband went the other way and primarily
speculated, not afraid to borrow money to
up his potential gain in his high risk investing.
Unfortunately for him, his investments were
high risk for a reason.
He squandered his $2 million fortune.
To try to dig out of his financial woes, he
got banks to lend money to him with the implication
that Hetty’s fortune was backing the loan,
even though this wasn’t the case.
He soon amassed massive debts, some of which
were known to Hetty who bailed him out of
his problems on a few occasions.
However, Hetty finally discovered the extent
of his debt after the collapse of John J.
Cisco & Son’s financial house, which Hetty
was the largest investor in.
It turns out, her husband was the biggest
debtor of the firm.
Needless to say, she gave him the boot.
(However, they remained married and in the
last few years of his life as his health deteriorated,
she took care of him and even converted to
Episcopalian before her own death so that
she could be buried beside him.)
Up to this point, Hetty had exhibited savvy
investing skills, along with a bull-dog like
business demeanor (fending off many an attempt
by groups of investors to ruin her, often
ultimately ruining them in the process).
But after separating from her husband, she
added in a slew of eccentricities, and the
public ate it up.
It’s difficult to separate the myth and
exaggerations from fact, particularly as she
was a woman who’d become wildly successful
in business in the 19th and early 20th centuries.
This was something not appreciated by many
powerful businessmen; so negative rumors about
her, probably generally baseless, were rampant.
That said, a few peculiarities that are backed
up with a reasonable amount of documentation
include that she constantly moved from district
to district in an effort to avoid having to
pay taxes in a given district, generally living
in the cheapest housing available despite
her fortune.
She also reportedly often used her dog’s
name on the records for her lodging, so as
to further throw any tax collectors off the
scent.
In addition to that, when her son injured
his leg at nine years old, rather than use
her fortune to get him the finest medical
care available, she initially took him to
a charity hospital.
However, contrary to what you’ll often read,
she later did take him to other doctors as
he continued to have leg problems for a few
years.
Ultimately, the leg became gangrenes and it
had to be amputated.
Beyond not liking to spring for medical care,
she also reportedly completely neglected personal
hygiene, and rarely washed or changed her
clothes.
Particularly in the summertime, the media
frequently reported that she stank.
They also reported that she constantly haggled
over the prices she had to pay for anything,
and whenever possible refused to pay if she
could get away with it and keep the item or
still acquire whatever service.
Perhaps one of her most famous tales had little
to do with her legendary stinginess.
In this case, it was a time when she pulled
a gun on railroad tycoon Collis P. Huntington.
Huntington was upset with the exorbitant prices
Hetty charged for small, but critically located,
railroads she’d acquired.
So he decided to try threatening her.
Specifically, he reportedly threatened to
have police and judges that were on his payroll
have Hetty’s son imprisoned.
Rather than giving in, her response was to
simply pull her gun out.
This is perhaps not surprising given Huntington
had made the mistake of threatening the only
two things Hetty seemed to care about- her
money and her children.
hetty-green1For all this, and more to the
point that she was a wildly successful woman
in the business world in an era where women
were expected to stay at home, she was dubbed
the “Witch of Wall Street.”
Perhaps more deservedly, her name became synonymous
with “miser” throughout the United States,
even later being named by the Guinness Book
of World Records as the “World’s Greatest
Miser.”
She would say of all this, “My life is written
for me down in Wall Street by people who,
I assume, do not care to know one iota of
the real Hetty Green.
I am in earnest; therefore they picture me
as heartless.
I go my own way.
I take no partner, risk nobody else’s fortune,
therefore I am Madame Ishmael, set against
every man.”
While exact amounts aren’t known precisely,
it is generally estimated that for her pre-three
ghosts, Scrooge-like life, by the time of
her death on July 3, 1916 at the age of 82,
Hetty had amassed a fortune of just over $200
million (about $5 billion today).
While she had groomed her son to take over
her fortune, teaching him everything she knew
about investing, he didn’t inherit her frugality
or aversion to giving to charities.
He spent and donated lavishly and despite
savvy investing as well (even weathering the
Great Depression mostly unscathed), by the
time of his death in 1937, his fortune hadn’t
risen at all, still about the $100 million
he inherited from his mother.
This all went to his sister, Sylvia, to add
to the $100 or so million she’d inherited
from Hetty.
Sylvia lived to 1951, ultimately leaving her
entire estate of about $200 million (about
$1.7 billion today) to various charities,
hospitals, universities, and churches.
So, in the end, despite Hetty having been
loath to spend, let alone give, away a dime
of money she didn’t have to, a large portion
of her amassed fortune ended up going to charity
thanks to her children.
Hetty wasn’t universally cheap.
One of the rare instances where she decided
to loosen her purse strings was for her daughter,
Sylvia.
Not only did she temporarily put her up in
an upscale hotel, but also provided her with
a fine wardrobe, all in an effort to find
her daughter a good husband (one that wasn’t
simply gold-digging), which she ultimately
did in the great-grandson of John Jacob Astor
I, Matthew Astor Wilks.
Wilks came to the marriage with $2 million
of his own money.
A paltry sum by Hetty’s standards, but enough
that she was convinced Wilks wasn’t just
after Sylvia’s inheritance.
Of course, she also made Wilks sign a pre-nup
stating he’d not be entitled to any of Sylvia’s
inheritance.
Hetty also sprung for the wedding.
Suitable for the stations of the families
involved, it was a lavish affair.
As for her son, Edward (known by Ned), she
also wasn’t always cheap with him.
She sent him to law school, then slowly began
allowing him to manage some of her investments
in order to continue the training she’d
began with him at a younger age.
He was successful at this in the various cities
she sent him.
After seeing this, she allowed him to use
some of the money she gave him to manage to
put himself up in fancy hotels, as well as
pay for his live-in prostitute Mabel Harlow
(who lived with him for the rest of his life)
and the steady stream of women Harlow managed
to procure for him.
Hetty thought this arrangement a good one
as she felt it helped shield her son from
the influences of the various gold-diggers
who were after the family fortune.
As his success in business grew, she called
him back home to manage her main investments
in New York, and didn’t complain when he
once again set himself up with Mabel in a
extravagant townhouse.
While Ned kept his promise and didn’t marry
while his mother lived, as soon as she died,
he married Mabel, with a pre-nup stipulating
that she’d get $1500 per month ($25,000
today) for the rest of her life.
Being married changed nothing about their
relationship though; she still continually
found him a steady stream of teenage girls
to serve as “private secretaries.”
Essentially, he’d grant each girl a trust
fund and pay for her education.
In exchange, for the duration of the girls’
schooling, they would stay at Mabel and Ned’s
home in Dartmouth on the weekends.
After contracting pneumonia at the age of
77 in one of her “cold-water,” cheap lodgings,
Hetty finally relented and sought out better
accommodations.
Even still, she worked out a deal where she
wouldn’t have to pay any more for the nicer
room.
She simply moved in with her son, agreeing
to pay him the paltry amount she’d paid
at her previous lodgings.
Among many other education-based charitable
contributions, Ned funded the building of
a radio transmitter by Dartmouth College which
was used to communicate with Richard E. Byrd
as he explored the Antarctic (1928-1930).
Later, after Sylvia had inherited the estate,
she donated Ned’s Round Hill house to MIT.
Scientists at MIT used the grounds for such
things as building a prototype atom smasher.